- We at Nintendo would
like to thank you for
making Pokémon Go the most
successful app of all time.
We also know that
playing Pokémon Go
can lead to some
tricky situations
so we are legally
obligated to remind you
to please be careful
while hunting.
Now let's meet Nathan.
Nathan loves Pokémon Go
but if he's not careful,
he could end up hurting himself.
- Charmander!
(crashes)
- So before you catch them all,
please remember to check out--
- Ooh, a Pidgey!
(playful music)
(thumps and crashes)
(breaks glass)
(boxing bell rings)
(crowd cheering)
(punches)
(bat cracks)
(crowd moans)
(slide whistle sound)
(cracks)
(yells)
(crashes)
(tires screech)
(door opens)
(door slams)
- [Man In Hoodie] Oh my god!
It's Pikachu!
Yes!
I caught it!
(playful music)